ich habe mich gefühlt wie der letzte
dreck bist du noch da ja
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum lang ersehnten
dritten und letzten teil unserer serie
zur dunklen triade nach nazismus und
materialismus widmen wir uns heute dem
wohl berühmtesten drittel der logen
triade nämlich der psychopathie
psychopath darunter stellt man sich
menschen vor wie hannibal lecter oder
allgemein kaltblütige mörder und
gewaltverbrecher dabei ist psychopathie
viel alltäglicher als die meisten meinen
ehrlichen war nazismus unterscheidet man
bei psychopathie zwischen einer
psychopathischen persönlichkeitsstörung
die ziele stehen zitiert werden kann und
so genannten sub klinischen ausprägungen
die angeblich jedem von cine ronan
bennett in verschiedenen ausmacht ein
kind das mit freude einen regen konzept
zeit bereits psychopathische anzahl
innerhalb der dunklen trial sind die
übergänge fließend vor allem in
kombination mit dem aktivismus tritt
immer häufiger man könnte aber sagen der
größte unterschied zwischen magna wie
listen und psychopathen ist die
impulsivität während magna wie listen er
kühlt ab wegen pannen dem psychopathen
oft inclusive oder aggressiv und sich
über die komik
helfen ihren gedanken zu machen die
erste kern ist es von psychopathie ist
ein mangel an empathie empathie ist die
fähigkeit sich in andere menschen
hineinzuversetzen und mit ihnen mit zu
fühlen forscher der universität
groningen untersucht und häftlinge bei
denen eine psychopathische
persönlichkeitsstörung diagnostiziert
wurde
mit hilfe von magnetresonanztomographie
untersuchten sie die hirnaktivität der
zoo basel während dieses video clips
schauen
die videoclips zeiten hände zweier
menschen die entweder neutrale
liebevolle schmerzvolle oder ablehnende
berührungen zeiten das heißt normales
berühren streicheln schlagen oder
wegstoßen dabei stellte sich heraus dass
die hirnaktivität der psychopathen
deutlich niedriger lag als die
kontrollgruppe von nicht psychopath
interessantes aber dass psychopathen
nichts grundsätzlich unfähig zu empathie
sind als man den privaten den ich sagt
die sollen sich doch bitte aktiv in die
anderen menschen also in die zwei hände
hineinversetzen konnte eine deutlich
höhere gehirnaktivität gemessen ist
könnte also sagen die empathie kann es
angeschaltet werden neben einem mangel
an empathie ist die zweite
charakteristische eigenschaft von
psychopathen eine besonders ausgeprägte
furchtlosigkeit psychopathen sind also
nicht nur impulsiv sondern auch
risikobereit und haben eine erhöhte
wahrscheinlichkeit an dinge wie
bungee-jumping spaß zu haben forscher
der uni bonn plädieren daher für einen
etwas differenzierteren blick auf
psychopathie ihren beobachtungen zufolge
sind psychopathen nicht zwingend
antisozial erfolgreiche psychopathen
können sozial sogar völlig unauffällig
sein wird sogar diskutiert ob die
furchtlosigkeit von psychopathen sie zu
besonders geeigneten
rettungsärzte oder feuerwehrleuten
machen könnte diese berufe setzen
natürlich eine gewisse selbstlosigkeit
voraus aber einen mangel an empathie ist
nicht zwingend gleichzusetzen mit
egoismus
zusammenfassend gesagt ein kaltblütiger
mörder ist mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
ein psychopath aber ein psychopath muss
noch lange kein kaltblütiger mörder sein
sondern vielleicht auch ein selbstloser
feuerwehrmann wie der rest der dunklen
trainer steckt psychopathie in jedem von
uns wenn ihr wissen wollte wie viele
psychopathie in euch steckt in der
infobox ist wieder der kleine
selbsttests falls ihr die noch nicht
gesehen habt ansonsten wenn ihr fragen
oder themenvorschläge habt schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare
wir sehen uns nicht nur seit wieder und
bis dahin bleibt sicher